hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled opportunities for using
packbow PacBio long read sequencing fork
Ovid 19 research this webinar is part of
the ongoing coronavirus virtual webinar
series I'm Christie jewel of labyrinth
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
Pacific Biosciences for more information
about our sponsor please visit PacBio
comm now let's get started I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits tab
located in the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Meredith
Ashby
dr. Ashby is a director of market
strategy for microbial and cancer
genomics at Pacific Biosciences for a
complete biography on dr. Ashby please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen welcome dr. Ashby you may
now begin your presentation
hi my name is that Meredith Ashby and
I'm the director of market strategy at
Pacific Biosciences focusing on our
microbiology applications so many of us
in the scientific community are looking
for ways that we can contribute to the
response to the Cova 19 pandemic and and
the same is true for all of us at PacBio
so I was very happy to be invited to
speak to you today about how our
technology might be useful to you as you
plan your own research efforts so I want
to preface my talk by saying that all of
the applications that I present here are
intended for research used only and
they're not intended for use in
diagnostic procedures so jumping right
into it how is PacBio sequencing
potentially helpful in your covin 19
research so to begin I want to I want to
start out by describing some of the
unique qualities of pec bio high five
reads and then go into more details
about how those qualities will be useful
in different types of applications
including SARS coast to genome
sequencing and then also understanding
the host response to to infection and
some of the topics that I'll discuss our
bcl PCR receptor sequencing also IgH
locus sequencing and finally HLA
sequencing so to start at the beginning
Peck bio is unique in that we are able
to produce not only long reads but breed
long reads that have very high accuracy
and this is quite well differentiated
from the other sequencing options that
you have available to you so how are we
able to do that so in the figure on the
right you'll see our smart bell which is
a template molecule for sequencing and
the nature of the smart Bell is such
that when it opens up we can sequence
multiple times all around the smart ball
over and over again and so even though
individual sub reads may have errors
this of those errors are completely
random in nature and by generating a
consensus accuracy from that one single
molecule we can generate high v reads
from these high fire reads have very
high
you see in our amplicon sequencing and
targeted sequencing application hi-five
reads can be as long as 15,000 base
pairs in length and they are over 99%
accuracy so this combination is it is
very interesting because the combination
of high accuracy with long relays allows
you to defames variants and also resolve
a repeat regions and to do that in such
a way that any variants you detect you
know are real and not just sequencing
errors
so my first application that I want to
talk about is far as close to sequencing
so how can high five sequencing help us
to understand the biology of this virus
so there's a few things that you might
want to do use one route sequencing for
the main main applications fall under
mutation phasing and rare variant
detection so these kinds of questions
are really important to researchers who
may be looking to understand the
epidemiology of the pandemic or to
develop vaccines or even therapeutics so
in order to determine where the virus
genome is stable and therefore
susceptible to attack you really need to
have information about variants that's
very highly accurate along the full
length of the genome and some
applications might include determining
you know what part of the virus that
antibodies are binding to successfully
and a successful immune response and
also for evaluating vaccine
effectiveness in addition long
resequencing can be very useful to
determining the virus population
structure so for example longer
sequencing will allow you to monitor the
evolution of the virus either within a
person over the course of infection or
between different regions or over time
as the epidemic proceeds and keeping an
eye on this evolution can be very
important for example making sure that
testing remains accurate that the virus
is not involved in such a way that the
test quality is compromised and in the
event that we finally do develop
therapeutics for Kovach over nineteen
it'll be important in tracking the
possibility of drug resistance emergence
and then finally can be very useful in
tracing and determining how people in
new communities whether they're becoming
infected as new carriers move into the
area or whether continued outbreak is
happening from silent carriers within
the
that our own country related and so then
one final application would be as
quality control and vaccine
manufacturing a lot of vaccines involves
live attenuated virus and one obviously
would want to make sure that the vaccine
being produced is the same as the one
that was developed and that the virus is
not mutating back to a more virulent
form during the course of production so
you may say that there's already very
accurate information being produced
about the FAR's kovtun virus and so I
want to just draw your attention to the
data that's currently available in Jess
JSA ID which is the Global Initiative on
sharing all influenza data so PacBio we
downloaded all approximately 3000
sequences that were present as of March
31st and this data contains assemblies
from all possible technologies and I do
want to highlight that currently there's
only two pack bottle sequences that are
available there so the information that
I'm showing you about PacBio data is
certainly not exhaustive or Trinity but
it is suggestive so the first thing I
want to point out is that many of the
genome assemblies in de sade are
actually quite low quality so if you
look at this graph this graph is an
assessment of how many segments of the
viral genome there are that are
separated by ends and so what you'll see
is that even with Illumina sequencing
about 40% of those assemblies have gaps
of ends in them and then if you look at
the ont assemblies that have been posted
about half of those assemblies have gaps
as well and so if you have gaps in the
sequence and that means that there's
regions of the virus where you really
don't know what's happening if there are
snips forming if they're mutations
forming and with this level of gaps it's
it's really quite impossible to
construct detailed phylogenies in order
to look at how the virus is evolving
over time in between regions
here's another way to look at that same
quality value so in this case we've
counted the number of ends in each of
these sequences and you can see that not
only there are there many gaps but some
of these gaps are very long so for
example in light green here these are
gaps that are over a hundred ends in
length so there's actually quite a lot
of missing information for most of these
genomes that have been submitted before
now
in contrast you'll see that the two
PacBio genomes that have been submitted
have no ends or gaps at all their
continuance and they cover the entire
viral region if you align a lot of the
sequences here either from Ont or
Illumina this is just a representative
subset what you'll also see is that
there are problematic regions where
there are consistently gaps in all of
these different assemblies and one
reason that we think that might be
happening is that if you are constrained
by using short amplicons that means you
have a lot less flexibility in where you
have to Park the primers and those
primer locations may not be optimal and
that may be resulting in poor sequence
quality in some regions
so why is it important to have very
accurate information so having higher
quality data makes it easier to identify
variable positions in the Stars Cove
genome and as I mentioned before the
locations of those variable positions
are really important for a number for
getting at a lot of research type
questions so in the top graph this is a
graph showing hot spots in the Stars
Cove - genome before any built quality
filtering is applied to the datasets all
right and then if you look in the lower
graph this is what that same metric
looks like after quality data filtering
and you'll see first of all that there
are hotspots that pop up in the fifth
quality filter regions that do not
appear significant in the pre quality
filtering and so this is the what I mean
by saying when you have long and highly
accurate sequence data this is what is
going to enable you to tell the
difference between sequencing era and
variants that are that are real
so there are already a number of
approaches that have been published by
other researchers that are compatible
with team saying PacBio protocols for
sequencing
so one protocol that a lot of people are
using right now is the arctic network
primers and so this is a 98 primer pair
protocol that produces relatively short
amplicons and these are absolutely can
be sequenced on the PacBio as is with
whatever bar coding strategy you're
already using and that can be done in
very high multiplex levels however
there's also two different protocols
that are available now that employ
average amplicon size of around 1,000
base pair amplicons
one is from the CDC and another is from
a publication by Julian Hiscox at the
University of Liverpool and you can look
at our website at comm slash co2 19 to
download those protocols which again
have been developed by other people and
then finally a we at PacBio are in a lab
and developing a longer amplicon
strategy so we appreciate that a lot of
the patient samples right now are highly
fragmented and that that makes it
challenging to amplify amplicons that
are longer however a lot of the research
questions that want to that are we're
going to have to begin dressing as the
crisis evolved are going to require
longer amplicon approaches and we feel
that oftentimes researchers will have
access to viral culture methods in order
to produce more intact virion from
patient samples and that these will be a
really useful research tool for doing
better phasing and phylogeny studies of
the virus
and then finally I mentioned that
amplicons can be multiplexed very highly
on tactile instruments and I just wanted
to cite one example of this we have a
customer a bear at University of Guelph
who is doing large-scale amplicon
sequencing in order to catalogue all the
forms of life that are present on the
planet today and in order to do that
obviously he has to sequence a lot of
amplicons because there's a tremendous
diversity and he has developed a
strategy to barcode and tool up to
10,000 amplicons in a single smart cell
and so there's no question that he can
sequence a large number of samples very
efficiently and in fact very
cost-effectively more cost-effectively
in Sanger and also more cost effectively
than NGS in some cases
so a lot of virus resources have already
been using PacBio for the reasons I
stated the ability to sequence complete
genomes and to fade sniffs and to do
quasi speedy determination and again if
you look on our Cova 19 website you'll
be able to see bunch of publications to
that effect and I wanted to just briefly
very briefly talk about two of those to
give you a sense of what's possible with
PacBio
so this is an article on altered single
molecule realsense sequencing of the HIV
end protein and so in this recent
publication the author's took multiple
samples from an autopsy of an
hiv-positive patient from all of these
different tissue types and then they did
full-length envelope sequencing of these
and then built the phylogeny showing how
all of the different virus quasi species
were related to each other from
different tissues and very interestingly
they found that there's actually a
strong compartmentalization of HIV n
sequences in the brain versus in the
rest of the body and that this in fact
had very important biological
significance because the two different
compartmentalized strains we're using
different receptors in order to gain
entrance to two cells but for our point
for our purposes I think the larger
point here is that these authors found
that since accurate reconstruction is
critical to do any kind of phylogeny
they chose to do smart sequencing and
that this is what allow them to get an
in-depth analysis to see this level of
stream diversification within just a
single patient and then findings in the
paper they note that the important
characteristic of tactile sequencing is
that it can potentially identify all the
diversity in each tissue and again
that's only possible because of the
combination of high accuracy and long
green lines and then I wanted to
highlight a second article very briefly
this is another recent article on
single-cell virus sequencing of the
influenza infection so
this is a paper where the author's
applied I so seek data which is our
version of RNA seek in order to sequence
both full-length influenza and also
immune response transcripts from single
cells and the typhoid Atta was able to
give them a comprehensive view of the
entire influenza mutational landscape in
each cell so if you look on to the right
this is just a subset of a very large
figure from the paper where the catalog
in every one of the 150 cells that they
sorted and sequenced every type of
mutation that is present in each of the
different genes present in influenza and
so you'll see hi-5 sequencing was able
to capture both point mutations in the
red close and open circles and then also
deletions which you can see in this
figure as yellow bars they were even
able to detect instances where two
slightly different viral variants were
present in the same cell and then
fascinatingly in the 150 infected cells
only 49 of those cells were still
wild-type 10 hours after infection so of
course we understand that the SARS co2
virus does not mutate quite so rapidly
but this is an extreme example of the
level of detail that you can get using
PacBio data and then the authors noted
that you know there your study provide
the first complete picture of how viral
mutations can affect the courses
infection at a single-cell level
so another area that PacBio sequencing
might be useful to you as you plan your
Kovac 19 research is in getting at the
host response to infection so the host
response kind of encompasses a couple
different things one is of course the B
cell development and the immune
repertoire that emerges as a result of
SARS co2 infection and some reasons that
you might want to look at those include
on you know finding broadly neutralizing
antibodies in recovered patients to use
as interim treatments ahead of the
development of a vaccine but we also
there's a lot of interest in
understanding why some patients get very
sick and others do not and one aspect of
this might be differences in in the
immune responses and then a final
application would be vaccine response
testing making sure that people are
mounting a sufficient response to the
vaccine that is going to be protective
area will beat with trying to delve into
the the germline sequences to understand
how allelic differences from person to
person might influence disease
susceptibility or disease progression so
a lot of the regions of the genome that
are involved in the immune response are
highly polymorphic and in the past have
been quite challenging to sequence and
to phase and so I want to talk briefly
about two examples one is the IgH locus
from which b cell development arises and
then also HLA sequencing
so I'm sure you all remember this quite
well from your college introductory
biology classes and immunology classes
but I want to briefly recap this because
it it helps me get to the point of
emphasizing why textiles can be useful
in studying b-cell receptor diversity so
how does b-cell receptor diversity arise
so it arises in it comes from primarily
three different sources the one is the
IgH locus contains a large diversity
different VD and J alleles and then
these are combined in order to produce
antibodies and you see in this graphic
at the top that's CDR 3 region precisely
where the VD and J regions come together
is a primary point of contact between an
antibody and the antigen but that's only
one source further diversity is added
because when those bdj regions are
spliced together it's done in a sloppy
manner with random and bases being added
between the different combining regions
but there's one more source of diversity
and that is somatic hypermutation so
after D cells are activated they undergo
this process by which additional
mutations are acquired as the D cells
divide and mutate very rapidly in the
journal Center and as a result of that
there are additional completely random
mutations that can be introduced
anywhere along the variable region and
not just in that CDR 3 region and the
reason this is significant is because
most short read strategies only sequence
of the CDR 3 region because of the
limitations on read length however with
PacBio you can sequence the entire full
length of the beach l receptor which
allows you to capture all of the
mutations that arise both during vdj
recombination and also during somatic
hypermutation
while additionally capturing isotype
information by sequencing the constant
domain and then the best part at all is
that since no assembly is required to do
this
were able to sequence it in one read the
base accuracy is very high and it's
consistent across the entire VCR
sequence whereas with short read
strategies assembly is required and it's
quite well known that there's a region
in the center where those breeds are put
together that can have lower accuracy
and in addition these cell receptors
that are longer than average may not be
able to be assembled at all and so those
be missing and that's significant
because often times the most effective
antibodies are ones that have undergone
multiple rounds of activation and those
tend to be longer than average
so if you are interested in doing
full-length BCR sequencing the pack
whales there is already a publication
that has a detailed protocol for doing
this and you can look up the artisan pcr
method which is published by Marvin
Koenig and his collaborators so the
general outline is very familiar to you
is that you prime from the constant
domain and then use the templates which
mechanism in order to sequence the
entire receptor so in most short read
protocols you would then do a nested
protocol and sequence only the ddr3
domain but with PacBio the nesting
priming for the PCR reaction also
happens within the within the constant
domain and so you capture the entirety
of that sequence
so in the artisan pcr paper one of the
key points is that not only is it
helpful to Jenna to capture all the
mutations but some pitfalls of using the
commonly used multiplex PCR method with
short reads were highlighted so this is
just one graph from that paper showing
that when they attempted to sequence the
b-cell receptor from a large number of
different cell lines including some
cancerous cell lines what they found is
that fairly often the multiplex PCR
failed to amplify those receptors and so
in cataloging the causes of that the
main cause was mismatches in the primer
binding site so with cancer obviously
you can get very untraditional mutations
in the PDA regions which makes it
difficult for multiply primers to bind
to those but it's also very well-known
that the full diversity of the VD and J
segments have not been adequately
documented and particularly not equally
well documented in all of the different
ethnic groups that are being impacted by
SARS co2 virus and that means that
alleles that are not known may or may
not be able to be picked up by the
current multiplex primers and so there's
a high risk of missing things that you
don't know about when your line is
multiplex PCR reaction another issue
that can arise is truncation of genes in
the sample and and again that falls into
the category of the more mutated the
b-cell receptor is the more challenging
it is to be picked up with this
multiplex PCR reaction and in this graph
here you can see as you move from left
to right
the researchers plotted the amount of
homology between the germline and the
sequenced receptor and they found that
the more that that b-cell receptor has
diverged from the germline the more
likely it is
have dropout in the multiplex PCR
reaction and again it's known from
studies of HIV and other types of viral
infection but the most effective broadly
neutralising antibodies tend to be the
ones that are developed through multiple
rounds of affinity maturation and tend
to be the furthest from the original
germline sequence
and so in conclusion this method is very
advantageous in that it lets you have
unbiased comprehensive analysis of the
entire B cell receptor repertoire in
either healthy or reactive conditions or
even in cancer
so one final area I wanted to talk to
you about is sequencing hi Liam
polymorphic regions of the genome that
are involved in the immune response so
this is a really interesting article
that was published by corey watson and
his collaborators looking at germline
sequence of the IgH locus so in the top
in the top graphic you'll see the finely
mapped sequence of the IgH locus in - in
one cell line pH 17 which is actually a
haploid cell line and then also in the
human reference genome and so these two
cell lines these two examples are unique
in that pH and 17 had a BAC library
which could be used to do thang or
sequencing in order to get this level of
resolution and of course the human
reference genome has been worked on
continuously but for you know over a
decade now in order to incorporate as
much detail as possible including in
very difficult to sequence regions so in
the past getting this level of
information was very difficult and quite
expensive however in this paper what
watkins and colleagues showed is that if
they were able to look at PacBio
reference genomes that have been
published and to pull down those
sequences and to compare them to the
high-quality references that were
available through more time-consuming
and expensive methods and the exciting
thing is that in all of these PacBio
reference genomes the IgH domain was
fully assembled and so they were able to
do comparative genomics showing that
there was a tremendous amount of
structural variation even in just a
snapshot of a very small number of
reference genomes that they were able to
draw from so excitingly there was a
there's going to be a follow-up paper to
this very soon
we're in Cori walks and we developed a
target capture method that's going to
allow this to scale up to
to get this type of detailed IgH locus
information from many many people and in
fact the new software tool that has been
developed for that purpose has already
been published and you could read that
yourself and look forward to Cory's next
publication which should be out very
soon
and so this is one example of the type
of work that I might be interesting to
do you're not going to start to
correlate allylic differences between
patients and differences in disease
severity or outcomes and one last area
where Peck bio has been used to look at
a little diversity in the immune system
is HLA sequencing so because of again
the combination of long read length and
high accuracy we are able to sequence
the hll genes in their full length and
that means that within one person the
two different alleles that are present a
sort very clearly and and so this
information it becomes easily accessible
Mace's also very has been very impactful
from our customers that are doing this
in terms of providing direct evidence
for new alleles that were not previously
known and in addition it's very calm
cost effective as it can be multiplexed
at a very high level and so why is it
important to have the complete sequence
of HLA instead of just the short
amplicons that are typically used with
it with an Illumina approach so that the
reason is that variants that are
occurring anywhere within the HLA genes
including in the introns can be
biologically meaningful and impactful so
this is data from a study the
retrospective study of about 900 stem
cell transplant recipient pairs and what
they did is they revile you ated the
quality of past matches by applying pack
bio full-length HLA sequencing to
matches that were previously done using
short read technology and this was done
at the Anthony Nolan Research Institute
so what they found is that when you have
a hundred percent matching
along the full length of all the HLA
genes that significantly improves
transplant survival so if you look on
the left the survival curve on the top
50 4.8% is the survival of patients that
had a complete match between the donor
and the recipient
and then the dotted line below are
instances where they found that upon
higher quality sequencing that there
were actually mismatches hiding in
regions of the HLA genes that were not
previously sequenced and what they found
is that that's very impactful and the
survival rate is nearly 20% less with
patients that have even that small level
of mismatch and of course on the right
it's quite well known that when you have
near matches even using the old
technology approach for example a less
than 11 out of 12 HLA match this already
was quite impactful to survival and it's
really the part on the left that was
surprising and having this new level of
resolution is obviously been very
attacked impactful for folks that have
to undergo stem-cell transplant but it
also opens the window to start to look
at how differences in these genes may
impact an immune response in other types
of contexts and not just stem-cell
transplant so if you're interested in
doing HLA sequencing we had several
service providers that you can contact
Anthony Milligan one it also just a
genetics and lab core as well so I
wanted to end just by saying that Peck
bio is is ready to support your co19
research even though we're in California
and the vast majority of us are under
the shelter-in-place order as you
yourself might be our shipping
department is still managing to to staff
building and we are sending out reagents
and fulfilling all of your orders on so
that we can support you all and then
finally if you want to have more
information on any of these protocols
or read more about any of the articles
that I discussed you can find links to
all of that at pac be calm slash cove in
slash nineteen and thank you very much
for your attention
as fee for your informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of our
webinar now to our audience if you have
any questions you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started dr. Ashby
our first question are there timelines
for the two to six KB amplicon protocol
yes so that work is ongoing in our Rd
Department and we are hopeful to have a
protocol that at least works on control
samples by mid next week the moment and
once we have those we'll be sending them
out to our collaborators who have the
capability to work with patient samples
in order to sequence those and see how
well they do with virus samples that may
be more degraded but I think in the
meantime it's a great chance to get
started with the 1kb amplicons that are
on our website the feedback we've gotten
from customers who are using that
protocol already is that even at 1 KB
there are a number of patient samples
that don't amplify because of the
degraded nature of the samples and then
if you the moment that we have the
longer amplicon protocols we will post
those to our covin IT and resource page
so you can always check they're very
good thank you and where can I get
packed by a sequencing done in these
times
yes so obviously there's a lot of flux
in terms of what sequencing sites are
open and which are closed and their
availability to do sequencing so the
best thing to do is that if you have a
project that you need sequence is to
email support as Pepe calm or you could
also go to Arkham Cove in 19 resource
page and scroll down at the bottom and
there's a you know ask a scientist
button and that we can put you directly
in contact with a service provider who
is still open in your area very good
thank you and do you provide technical
support yeah absolutely and you don't
even have to be a direct customer of
tech bio to get support from us even if
you're a customer of a sequencing core
you can always email support xpcom or go
to our website to get in touch with our
support team and we're very happy to
help you plan your project or to work
through the technical details that you
want to do your own library prep very
good thank you
now dr. ask me this next question is two
parts is the library prep and data
analysis complicated and is it possible
to automate either or both yeah so the
great thing is that it's actually quite
simple so for the library prep since
PacBio sequencing is so very accurate
you can if you you can actually use
whatever amplicons that you would
already generate for you know shorter
amplicon protocols that you might want
to run on a short breeze platform and
you can run those on the tech bio so and
any service provider would be able to do
the let that library prep for you that
last step and again if you did want
support with that you can always email
us and in terms of data analysis again
since the PacBio data is so highly
accurate you can actually take our data
as it comes off the machine as hi-five
reads and you can use whatever pipeline
that you would normally use for your
short read data to do analysis one of
the tools that our virus customers like
to use a lot is genius we also have
a tool called Juliet that helps do minor
variant detection so it's very easy and
if you have more specific questions
we're very happy to get online with you
and answer those very good thank you
our next question why is having the IgH
locus
um I guess sequence important isn't
having the bdj a lilies enough yeah
that's a really great question
and I think for a long time people did
think that just having the vdj alleles
that are present in a given person was
enough to explain differences in the
mutant response among other folks but
the work that Cori Watson has been doing
initially in life and now follow-on
studies in humans shows that it's not
just whether you have a vbj allele or
not it's also really important what the
genetic context is because oftentimes a
vdr je allele can be present but it
doesn't show up very well in the music
repertoire or it shows up in different
at different rates depending on snips or
structural rearrangements in the IgH
locus so it's really important to have
not just the video genes but also the
IgH locus to understand the expression
levels and the accessibility of the vdj
segments
thank you now early data seems to
indicate that stars Kobe too doesn't
mutate as quickly as influence do you
think long route sequencing will still
be important for variant detection
that's a really great point and it's
true that it does seem like SARS co2
doesn't mutate it's rapidly something
which is really great news obviously for
vaccine development that said there are
already several reports of deletions in
the spike protein and in delft elsewhere
in the other open reading frames that
could be significant and I would not be
surprised that as the pandemic continues
and particularly if there are tunics are
developed that as the virus comes under
more selective pressure that we might
start to see adaptation or other strains
start to mutate out
thank you now we have time for just a
few more questions but I want to let our
audience know that those questions we
are unable to answer today and those
that are submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and let's
see let's go with this final question
are you looking to partner with
companies to Co market approaches for
covin 19 such as with a company
specialized in bioinformatics that can
help with data analysis for copan 19 we
are always happy to work with
third-party companies both for sample
prep work or for data analysis and so I
think the best way to do that would be
to have our laboratories connected with
me or you can also just go to the
support at Peck be calm and that will
find its way to me or the appropriate
person very good thank you dr. Ashby and
we need you for your time today and for
your important research and before we go
I would like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions again those
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
now this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through the end of this year 2020 and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thanks for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon have a great
day